the saga is ending but will the story
live on forever on December 16th the 9th
Star Wars film and the final installment
of the Skywalker saga the rise of
Skywalker had its world premiere in Los
Angeles critics took to social media
following the event to share their
thoughts about the film we hesitate to
say that there's a general consensus
about the rise of Skywalker at this
point since full reviews have yet to be
posted online and because critics are
barred from revealing too much in their
early reactions what we can say however
is that there have been more positive
reactions to the film than negative ones
with a common thread and critics tweets
being that the rise of Skywalker is a
larger than life better than expected
conclusion to the 40-plus year long
Skywalker saga fandango's Erik Davis
held nothing back he tweeted epic all of
it
the film is a terrific finale that is
just stuffed with so much of everything
action adventure answers humor heart
love and grit I spent the entire second
half with tears in my eyes a wonderful
way to end the skywalker story
entertainment journalist Jenna Bush was
moved to tears during the premiere of
the rise of Skywalker as it checked
every box and delivered on every promise
she tweeted oh my god
I am absolutely blown away I've never
been so satisfied by a film this is the
end of an era and a franchise that has
defined my life and this did it justice
in a way I didn't imagine it could you
will cry shortly after seeing the rise
of Skywalker on Monday evening /phone
founder Peter Cerreta tweeted JJ Abrams
nailed it he was able to bring a
cohesive arc to this trilogy that feels
like a fitting end to the saga as a
whole I'm so emotionally drained Star
Wars fans will be very happy it appears
that one way the rise of Skywalker
accomplishes the lofty goal of ending
the Skywalker saga with a bold bang it's
through fanservice which critics have
conflicting emotions about I got a bad
feeling about this
the official Twitter account for cinema
blends tweeted that the rise of
Skywalker is quote jammed with
fanservice
but the kind that will probably divide
fans and spark heated discussions about
the Star Wars universe
film and television critic Yolanda
Machado sure that she wasn't entirely
surprised by the events of the rise of
Skywalker and felt that quote too much
fanservice was given however those
downsides didn't detract from the
overall greatness of what the rise of
Skywalker does and accomplishes in her
eyes machado tweeted that the film is
quote everything and nothing that you're
expecting she went on to say god I love
this franchise and I'll miss the
Skywalker saga award-winning journalist
and film critic Scott mance had similar
feelings about the fanservice in the
rise of Skywalker there
a lot of it but he really enjoyed the
film as a whole he made no mention of
what the results of packing so much
fanservice into the film might be though
instead keeping his reaction contained
his own excited thoughts he tweeted
really awesome the best of the new
trilogy really fun lots of humor a big
heart so many surprises it's everything
Star Wars fans are hoping for and more a
very satisfying conclusion a lot of
fanservice but I loved it you know the
old saying too much of a good thing is a
bad thing for some critics this adage
applies to the rise of Skywalker
Mashable's Chris Taylor kept his
feelings about the rise of Skywalker's
short and simple unlike what he felt the
movie was he wrote the rise of Skywalker
is a lot it's like 9 movies of plot and
one going to take me about nine days to
process an G jaehun also of Mashable
Eiko Taylor sentiments and tweeting up
the rise of Skywalker is a lot she
expanded quote tons to live here no
shortage of crowd-pleasing moments and
twists and cameos but also quite a bit
to think about han also hinted at it
emotionally fulfilling send-off for
carrie fisher's leia organa
and some heartwarming moments with new
characters jana and d0 a little droid
pal who looks like he has a megaphone
for a head collider editor-in-chief
Steven Weintraub was particularly
cryptic in his reaction to the rise of
Skywalker but what he did offer
following the premiere of the film
suggests that he may not have enjoyed it
on Monday night he tweeted I might be in
the minority on the rise of Skywalker I
have a lot to say but we'll wait till
after it is open I have a bad feeling
about this okay okay you guys we get it
it goes without saying that these are
but a selection of many first reactions
to the rise of Skywalker that critics
were able to put out on social media
without getting into hot water with the
legal departments at Disney and
Lucasfilm far more in-depth reviews of
the film will be available to read once
the companies lift the review embargo
for the rise of Skywalker on Wednesday
December 18th at 12:01 a.m. Eastern Time
a full day before Thursday night
previews begin on December 19 as the
world witnessed in 2017 with the last
Jedi everyone is going to have their own
unique opinion about the rise of
Skywalker and there could be a big
divide between critics and fans once the
flick officially launches in theaters
while absorbing other people's reactions
to a movie is generally a harmless hype
boosting activity and lead up to the
premiere it's important to remember that
just because millions of people love the
same property you do it doesn't mean
you'll see eye to eye with them that
said it's best to head into your rise of
Skywalker's greetings this week with an
open mind that's prepared for anything
and everything to happen you may love it
or you
hate it but the only way to find out is
to see the rise of Skywalker yourself on
Thursday December 19th check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff for coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and at the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]